okay this is a great voicemail follow-up
this is a voicemail in Spanish I will
translate it for you it is all about my
phone call last week with a caller
claiming to be named Pedro claiming to
be from the country of Colombia and
clearly he is not take a listen to this
I will translate don't worry delightful
voice memo pedo cannot be Colombian come
when I kill people people because a
Colombian Lee he said key don't anything
English Quito
not that he protested Quito tavella's
you have to keep up a red mass so Aikido
sorry for Korean see that produces ok
person obtained committee he died like a
Sunday in Colombia Quito ok so what the
person is saying is first of all that
Pedro obviously has a real or fake
Mexican accent he doesn't sound at all
like he's from Colombia but this was a
big misunderstanding
people thought that I referred to the
capital of Colombia as Quito but that I
mispronounced it
Hido that's not what I did there's a
part of Colombia called
IDO qu I be do with an accent over the
oh it's obscure and only people from
Colombia would know about it so my
thought was to bring it up to trick him
and he seemed to say yeah yeah yeah
that's the capital so I know that Quito
is not the capital of Colombia I
mentioned keep though which is a region
or part of Colombia that seemed to
really perplex Pedro in any case we love
Pedro and hopefully he'll call back
someday
do me a favor take a three-question
20-second survey at david pakman.com
slash survey we are asking our audience
how affected you are by coronavirus
it takes just 20 seconds david
pakman.com slash survey I think the
results will be interesting totally
anonymous we will see you on today's
bonus show